Rio de Janeiro is famous for its
waterfront
clear waters and white sand beaches but
just down the road in guanabara Bay the
scene is very different
a graveyard of ships
dozens of boats abandoned and left to
rest
these vessels are old and their owners
don't use them so they abandoned them
this is a crime
it's gone on for years ignored by most
people but a stormy evening in November
quickly changed that
the saluese a large and rusted cargo
ship Broke Free and drifted across the
harbor
it crashed into Latin America's longest
bridge over water and forced the closure
of one of Rio's main commuter routes in
the middle of Rush Hour
now the Navy is investigating but
environmentalists say more needs to be
done
the crash Drew attention to the
existence of this graveyard of ships San
Luis remains in Rio's port with 50 tons
of fuel inside it it's a ship with high
corrosion it's not safe and it can cause
an environmental disaster
they're already seeing the impact heavy
pollution is threatening Turtles and
seahorses and the Bay's dolphin
population has dropped from 800 to only
34. fishermen and the broader economy
are also paying the price
I used to fish I used to catch 100 kilos
of fish quickly now to catch 50 kilos of
fish it will take a week or a month one
Environmental Group says the pollution
is costing millions of dollars in Lost
production
after the crash local media said
officials began studying how to remove
the so-called ghost ships from the bay
but while they're studying the options
these skeletons are sinking deeper into
its Muddy Waters and for those sounding
the alarm it's a crisis that needs to be
treated with urgency
Alexandra Byers Al Jazeera